rock your character's name is a doctor
smolder brave stone yes so all the
guards have strengths so one of your
strengths is the smolder an actual
smolder yes this takes over and I have
no control of did you know you could
smolder like did you kind of think yeah
I wouldn't do when you read it you gotta
go oh yeah I'll do my smolder you know I
took you know it didn't come yet okay
okay literally is where it came from
that what you're saying and this is why
he looked at me cuz it's so frustrating
just go ahead tell the tell the story
about you it's one of those things that
you know as we're developing the script
and thinking well what could be a fun
thing well would have a fun thing one of
the fun things was he has this ability
to smolder and it just takes over him he
has no control of it and and it's just
one of those things Graham that day
ain't God delivered I signed for it
everyone likes it and everyone loves it
except one individual okay now we are we
are very close we were very close as
friends and you know in this position
he's a producer on the film so sometimes
I just bit my tongue so this idea came
up from a producer like mentality oh you
know what it'd be great for this
character if he's smoldered not like you
know he did a thing
[Music]
he's warning back he's like my mom used
to do it to me when I was everything
back to Hawaii that's how you did it
great forgive me see you smolder we saw
I'd be happy to breaks it back
[Applause]
can we have a little music maybe
something that's a little ominous may
okay here we are
Wow yes okay okay here we go you can do
it to me if I could be there right here
we go
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
having a baby grevilles pebble it's a
little wrong it's good gets into the
rocks that's my you are who you are
[Applause]
[Music]
you